>> Austin: AND IT'S QUI
AND NOW I'M PUT IT INTO THAT THE
GIVES TO MOBLEY.  SKY.
>> John: TAKE A LISTEN.
23-YEAR-OLD OUT OF TEXAS.
LOVED HIM WITH THE NATS AND
HE'S BETTER WITH THE CAB.
>> HE GOES UP ABOVE AND OVER
CAPELA
ALL-STAR BRAM R BREAK AND DOWN
THE STRETCH.
INSIDE, OKORO.
AND AGAIN GREAT DEFENSE BY THE .
>>T THIS PASS TO SET UPMOBLEY.
GET IT BACK. CORNER.
6 TON A GOOD JOB OF
DRAWING --
GARLAND.
CAVS PUT ON THE ACCELERATOR.
A 20-POINT LEAD.
THAT'STHEY
CONTRACTED.
YOU WOULDN'T FEEL GOOD ABOUT
GOING TO THE DEDE WILL NOTALLEN
THERE GOES
>> Austin: COMPLETE HAND ON THE
BALL.
GET THAT ALLEN ON THE WEAK
SIDE.
>> John:OTHING. SIDE WITH
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE LANE
AND MASON PLUMLEE HAS TO,
YOU FORCE THE TEAM ACTUALLY COME
HELP. GUARDED I TORREY CRAIG.
INSIDEGOOD PASS BY LOVE.
THROW THE HAMMER DOWN.
ONE-POSSESSION
JOB OF SPINNING THE THEM MOVE T
INJURY.
>> NOTSQUARE.
UP OVER THE TOP.
FOLLOW THROUGH STRAIGHT IN FOR
THREE.
DEALS  OUR BIG
THE CAVS WILL HAVE A LONG ROAD
SCRAMBLING FASHION.
UPSTAIRS
ALLEN
BACK THEY PROTECTED BY, BS, TWO,
C
OUT COMES THE CAVALIERS T
HIS HEAD UP.
A  ELBOWED.
ALLEN.
AUSTIN: STRAIGHT UP DEFENS